ce jeune britannique est l'un des
volontaires qui a accepté d'être infecté
par l'aco vite pour faire avancer la
recherche sur les vaccins
un peu partout dans le monde des
milliers d'autres ont fait comme lui en
s'inscrivant sur des sites qui leur
offre de jouer les cobayes il va
participer à ce qu'on appelle un humain
challenge habituellement dans un humain
challenge on injecte d'abord un vaccin
aux participants et ensuite le virus
qu'on veut combattre puis on observe le
résultat mais cette fois ci on lui
injecte seulement le coronavirus
l'objectif déterminer la dose minimale
de virus nécessaires pour rendre une
personne malade est utilisée ensuite
cette dose pour tester des vaccins c'est
évidemment une expérience rare et
controversés c'est des choses qui sont
déjà fait dans le passé mais ici on
parle d'un virus qui est potentiellement
mortelle donc il faut faire vraiment
très très attention et il faut qu'ils y
obtiennent toutes les autorisations que
tout soit extrêmement bien bien établis
avec des bons paramètres à suivre
l'essai clinique qui enroule uniquement
des personnes jeunes et en bonne santé a
aussi ses limites
le problème est qu'on ne sait pas encore
si un vaccin qui protégerait de 18 à 30
ans fonctionnerait nécessairement pour
les personnes plus âgées qui sont plus à
risque le human challenge qui devrait
débuter d'ici deux mois avec un petit
groupe de cobaye les responsables n'ont
pas encore obtenu l'autorisation finale
d'aller de l'avant
lorsque les human chaline sont autorisés
ils permettent généralement d'accélérer
le développement des vaccins en phase
finale
ici norma grandin reste du canada
montréal